If I wanted to write the perfect essays,
then these are the five things that I
would focus on. And you can think of
them as five locations that readers use
to interpret and understand your text.
They're the places that readers look to
find key information. And so, if when
you're editing, you put the right
information in these locations, then
readers are going to find your text a
lot easier to use. They're five tools
that I've developed across my 10 years
of teaching academic and professional
writing, and they're what I've used to
help my clients get funding, pitch
startups, and become a thought leaders
in their field. And for each one, I'm
going to describe what it is and how it
works from the perspective of reader
psychology, because that's what really
counts. Not what I say is the right way
to use an essay, but how we know that
readers read and how they're going to
use your text. And so, if you've ever
published and you've had great ideas,
but your essay just didn't seem to take
off in the way that you hoped it would,
this video is for you. And so, the first
thing we need in a good essay is a good
title. Because, well, if you already
like a reader, then you'll read pretty
much anything they write. But, if you
want your essay to take off, then what
you need to do is reach cold readers.
Readers who don't know you, probably
don't even like you, and have never read
your stuff before. And so, in order to
do that, we need to avoid some common
pitfalls when it comes to writing a
title. Some writers like to use a kind
of key concept or insight, maybe a
metaphor, that they've developed in the
course of their body and put that into
the title. But, that doesn't work
because it's almost like an inside joke.
It's the kind of thing that only makes
sense after you've read the essay. So,
you want to avoid those kinds of cryptic
titles, or the ones that only make sense
after the reader has read your essay.
And instead, you want to design
something that catches their attention
and intrigues them. So, how do we do
that? Well, we actually have some pretty
good psychological research about the
psychology of intrigue. What makes
people curious? And basically, at the
bottom of it all, there are four things.
So, try to make sure that your title is
playing on one of these four qualities,
which are
pose a question or a puzzle,
open a sequence of events with an
unknown resolution,
violate their expectations,
and signal that others know something
that they don't.
Now, the reason this works is because
whenever the title succeeds at picking
their curiosity, then they'll click
through, and the next part of the job,
which is to get them to read the rest of
the essay, will be taken up by the
introduction. Now, we'll touch on that
in just a second, but a good format, a
really tried-and-true format for titles
is to use, you know, one kind of
eye-catching title, something that plays
off of the intrigue, and then you you'll
often see
these three nouns that come after it.
And it's really good if you can have
these nouns cohere with kind of three
key concepts that you develop throughout
the piece, because these link forward
into the text. And when readers see this
kind of correspondence between, you
know, concepts here and concepts here,
they experience your text as coherent.
And by the way, if you want to get this
visual guide for yourself, you can grab
a free copy down below the like button.
It includes all the frameworks that I
used to teach nonfiction writing, and
it's only four pages long, so you can
print it off and tape it up on your wall
and just refer to it anytime you're
writing. And now, the second thing that
I would focus on if I wanted to write a
great essay is the introduction. And in
my teaching, whenever I'm working
one-on-one with clients, this is the
place where I spend a disproportionate
amount of time because it has a really
important function. After you have
convinced readers to click through to
your essay and open it up, that's the
first hurdle. But the next hurdle after
that is to motivate them to read the
rest of the essay. And that's a big ask
because now they're looking at maybe
2,000, 5,000 words, depending on how
long your essay is. So, this
introduction really it it has that
function. It needs to convince readers
to keep going. And to convince them that
it's going to be worth their while. So,
that's why a lot of the patterns that
we've learned, primarily in school, but
also through different frameworks that
you see shared online, it's why they
don't work. In school, they taught us
that an introduction is supposed to go
from the background information to the
thesis. Or maybe they've told you to
move from general to specific in that
kind of inverted triangle. Or in
university, they might have told you to
move from a gap to a niche to say this
person studied this and this person
studied that, but nobody has studied
this thing. However, none of those
really do the work of motivating. They
work in school because in school, your
reader is your teacher. And your teacher
does not require motivation. Their their
their motivation to read your paper
comes from their salary. That's their
motivation. So, there's nothing in the
paper that needs to It's nice if there's
if there's something compelling in the
paper, but the function of the paper is
not to communicate. It's to express your
ideas. It's to show the teacher that
you've actually done the work, that you
read the book, that you did the
assignment. That's the function of the
of the paper in school. But, in the real
world, when you're dealing with real
readers, they are not interested in what
you know. They want to use your text as
a medium of communication. And just as
in a conversation, you would never go
down rabbit holes and just start talking
about whatever you're interested in,
regardless of what the what the listener
is interested in, similarly in your
text, you need to effectively say, "I've
got this idea, and here's why you should
care about it." Right? Here's why it's
useful to you. And so, I really think
that the way to set up your introduction
is to step away from these
information-based
patterns, you know, general to specific,
gap to niche,
background information to thesis, and
instead use your introduction to set up
a problem. Readers care about problems.
It bugs them. You You see this in drama,
too. Every drama, every story, is about
someone who wants something but can't
get it. And similarly, your reader is
one of those people. There's something
that they want in the world, and there
are problems in the world that are
causing preventing them from getting it.
So, for your idea to be valuable, we
need to position it as the solution to a
problem. And I can I've gone more in
depth about this before, so I won't go
too deep into the the theory of
introductions, but effectively, a good
introduction has three parts, which is
common ground, a problem, and a
solution.
We start off with the common ground, we
show reader what's wrong with the common
ground, and we position our ideas as the
solution to that problem. That's it.
Your introduction is it's not just
enough to build an inverted triangle to
your idea because that's just a pile of
information.
All that kind of introduction is saying
is you have some information, here's
some more information. It's not showing
the value of your ideas or rather it's
assuming that your ideas are valuable
just because they're yours. In other
words, these models come from an
expressionist framework. They assume
that ideas are valuable just because you
express them. But what we want is a
rationalist framework where we
understand that an idea is valuable only
so far as it's useful. So we need to
position your ideas as useful. We need
to show what problem does your idea
solve? Because that way a reader who
cares about that problem is going to
care about your solution and thus
they're going to read your asset. Now
the third feature that I would focus on
if I wanted to write a great essay is a
fractal pattern called the index and the
discussion. It's easiest to talk about
this or to picture it when we're
thinking about paragraphs. So I've kind
of illustrated it down here. But
honestly, this pattern is one that we
see at every level of resolution, right?
The whole essay is an index and
discussion
and then that that discussion is broken
up into parts and then
each part has its own index and
discussion. So this pattern, this
fractal pattern occurs at every level of
resolution. But again, it's most
straightforward to talk about if we just
think about it in terms of one
paragraph. So what is this pattern?
Well, the index is the location at the
top or beginning of a paragraph or a
unit of discourse where readers look to
find out what's going on. In the context
of a single paragraph, the index is
going to be one to three sentences long.
But of course, as you expand this out,
it could be a few paragraphs depending
on how long the section that it governs
is. And that that's really what it is.
Like the index sets the context for
interpretation.
When the readers are looking at a unit
of discourse, whether it's a paragraph
or a group of paragraphs in a section or
even a whole chapter, they look to the
opening of that unit to figure out what
the rest of the piece is about. Now, the
important thing to understand about this
fractal pattern is that it's not
something that I'm prescribing for you.
It's something that your reader sees
intuitively. They're going to perceive
this pattern whether you intended or
not. So, if you're not aware of this
pattern, if you're not thinking about it
at each level of resolution in your
text, then readers are going to see it
anyway. And if they're using the index
to interpret the discussion and you're
not intending it, then now what you're
doing is you're giving them context in
the index that is confusing their
interpretation. They read the index and
they say, "Okay, I see this section is
going to be about, you know, this idea."
But then they go on and read and they
find, "Huh? What? This is about
something different."
Okay, so readers perceive this
intuitively. But again, let's focus on
the context of a single paragraph. So,
within the context of a paragraph, the
index is going to be one to three
sentences long.
You sometimes hear this spoken about in
school writing as a topic sentence. But
I don't really think topic sentences are
a useful way to think about this because
well, first of all, readers don't value
topics. So, if you think of this
location in terms of topic sentences,
then it's you're going to be putting
topics into that location, and readers
don't really care about topics. They
care about problems. So, it's more
useful to think about
the index as the place where you set up
the problem that the discussion is going
to address. But second, it's not helpful
to think about these as a topic sentence
because often, if you look at
professional prose, a topic sentence can
be more than one sentence. It'll be two
to three sentences within the context of
a paragraph. So, a good um test of this
index to see whether you're using them
properly is just is called the skim
test. And so, with the skim test, you
should be able to skim the index
position
of each of your paragraphs and each of
the sections and see whether it tells a
coherent story.
If the first one to three sentences of
your paragraphs don't kind of
storyboard, they don't line up in a way
that's that's coherent and that makes
sense, something's gone wrong here. So,
within the scope of a single paragraph,
how do you use the index? Well, again,
I've said it's one to three sentences
long, so generally, try to keep it one
sentence, but you can expand it to two
or three three sentences is basically
the limit, but you can expand it to
three sentences whenever you're writing
about something complex, whenever you're
opening with an opposition, right?
Whenever you say something that's
effectively like X, however, Y,
and that opposition kind of governs the
idea that's going to be developed in the
paragraph,
or whenever you're posing a question.
You might say X, Y X. Well, as we will
see, Y. But now, within the index, you
see these three lines, and that's the
section of a great essay that we're
going going about next. It's called a
key term. Now, a key term is a preview
of some of the important concepts that
are going to be developed in the
discussion section.
You want to see some coherence through
repetition
or close synonym.
Right? You You want You want a kind of
constellation of terms. And so, let me
show you what I mean. Here's a paragraph
that uses key terms effectively. It's
from James Frazer's The Golden Bough.
And so, in the index up here, we see
some key terms that are going to be
repeated throughout the passage. So, it
says, "Other people besides the Arabs
have used fire as a means of stopping
rain."
The Sulka of New Britain, see Sulka
belongs kind of under the umbrella of
Arabs. It's a member of that group. So,
it's not a repetition, but it's still
part of that kind of constellation of
key terms. So, the Sulka of New Britain
heat stones red hot in the fire and put
them out in the rain. They think the
rain will soon cease to fall, for it
does not like to be burned. The Telugas
send a little girl out into the rain
with a burning piece of wood to show
them to show to the rain. At Port
Stephens, the medicine men drive away
rain by throwing fire sticks into the
air. Any man of the Anula tribe can stop
rain by warming a green stick in the
fire and striking it against the wind.
So, these colors create what are called
topic strings. There is a kind of
constellation
of terms that just belong together. And
there aren't really a lot of nouns that
don't directly link back to some of the
concepts that were announced in the
index. I have another example here, and
again, if you get that PDF download, you
can read them more carefully. But, the
important reason that we want to do this
is because readers what when you read a
text like this, subconsciously, it seems
like it all fits together. That's what
we call coherence.
When the pieces belong together and they
kind of snap together to create a
like a puzzle piece, right? The The
sentences fit together, and when you
zoom out, there's a kind of coherent
picture. Everything there belongs, and
there's nothing here that doesn't
belong. That's the important thing. The
The new concepts that we're introducing
in the discussion are announced in the
index. And then, nothing in the
discussion does not link everything in
the discussion, say it positively,
everything in the discussion links back
to the index. There's nothing in there
that doesn't belong. And so, that's what
we call a key term. Now, the last piece
that I would want to focus on if I was
trying to write a great essay is the
conclusion. And so, that advice that we
were given in school where, you know,
you should sum up your points in the
conclusion, I think again that belongs
to that positivist mentality where
your ideas are valuable because they're
yours, right? Because they're
information, that's what makes them
valuable. So, instead, we here have been
defining value as a solution to a
problem. And so, if in the introduction
you opposed a problem and then presented
your idea, your thesis, as the solution
to that problem, well, then through
these index discussion blocks, these
these paragraphs and sections, you have
unpacked that solution. You've proven
it. And so, now in the conclusion, you
want it to kind of mirror the
introduction. You want to return to the
problem that you pose and show how your
idea has resolved it at a very high
level. And what do I mean high level?
Well, this pattern over here is a good
way of thinking about the development of
your text. So, it's a this is a measure
of specificity, of detail. Where up in
level five, you have a general kind of
abstract information, and then down at
the floor, you have more specific
concrete information. So, this would be
our index, and this would be like
evidence. It could be a quote or a
statistic, but it's like data,
uninterpreted
raw evidence. And so, if that's the
progression pattern, then you would
begin here with the introduction,
setting up a problem and positioning
your idea as the solution to the
problem. And then through the body, we
would be going through and unpacking
that and showing
how it works through all these various
subpoints. And now we're done, and the
point of this pattern is to say we don't
want to end on the same level of
specificity to where we began. We don't
just want to recapitulate
the the point the point or the problem.
Instead, we want to end on a higher
level of detail than [clears throat]
where we began, because that gives your
essay a kind of forward thrust.
So, how do you do that? Well, not it's
almost like you're saying,
"Okay, here's a problem, and if you read
this essay, I promise I'm going to solve
that problem for you." And then you go
down and you solve that problem in
various ways, and then when you're
coming up, you do not want to just end
and say, "See, told you so." Right? You
You do want to say that, but you want to
go farther than that. So, you you would
say, "Now that we have this problem
solved, we now have to think about this
broader issue, or maybe this solution
changes our understanding of a broader
concept that is important to think
about. And so at a very simple level,
you just want to think of your
conclusion as showing that the problem
is solved and showing how that solution
contributes
to a broader discussion. Right now that
we've solved this, here's how you can
use this idea to think about this
broader discussion that's going on.
There are various ways that you can do
this, but the essential point here is to
say in your conclusion, try to push off
of your solution to something a a more
broader conversation. Maybe one that
your reader is already invested in. But
now if I were to focus on only one of
these five elements of a great essay, I
would definitely focus on the
introduction because it's the 80/20 for
great writing. The 20% of work that you
do that gets you 80% of the results. So
if you want to find out more about this
approach to writing an introduction, you
need to check out this video next
because it's going to show you my
five-part structure for developing an
essay and I'm going to do it live on
someone's essay so you can see how to do
it yourself. So be sure to go check it
out.